brand new details is the Federal
indictment of Donald Trump gets unsealed
the former president getting hit with 37
charges in the classified documents case
Trump's aide also getting indicted the
feds say there are two instances of
Trump's showing classified material to
people including a military plan of
attack against an unnamed country
Trump's accused of directing an aid to
move documents out of a storage room
before an FBI subpoena the doj also
claiming that Trump suggested to his
lawyer that they should hide or destroy
the documents the former president will
appear in federal court Tuesday in Miami
and is proclaiming his innocence
and we had tremendous support
but that was a hoax and a scam and now
they're doing it again it's just a
continuation seven years if I'm an
innocent man I did nothing wrong and we
will fight this out just like we've been
fighting for seven years it would be
wonderful if we could devote our
full-time to making America great again
special counsel Jack Smith breaking his
silence but not taking questions on why
he decided to indict Trump
our nation's commitment to the rule of
law sets an example for the world
we have one set of laws in this country
and they apply to everyone it's very
important for me to note that the
defendants in this case must be presumed
innocent until proven guilty Beyond A
Reasonable Doubt in a court of law Joe
Biden saying that he doesn't know what
the Joe Biden doj was doing
Mr President have you spoken to attorney
general Merrick Garland yet
[Music]
and the liberal media has been popping
the champagne since the news broke
I don't know it's it's sad and it's
shocking but it's also kind of real it
makes me feel a bit relieved line by
line by line of this indictment lays out
calculation deliberate misconduct you
can see the voluminous nature of this
that they have the goods and the
receipts this bad news I have never seen
anything hit Donald Trump this hard that
sound that you hear is silence largely
from Republicans in these moments maybe
they're reading this 50-page document
the taped conversation is that a Smoking
Gun do they consider as part of a
potential plea offer something that
would prescribe him prescribe him from
from running for office again
Judge Jeanine PIRA you've been reading
the indictment how would you
characterize it
you know I am so livid right now I am
furious I have spent over three decades
in a system that I believe in I'm a
Believer but today I am no longer a
Believer what you've got is a weaponized
Department of Justice Department of FBI
and CIA we saw it from the time he came
down that that escalator they started
with the Russia collusion hoax and we
know that Hillary Clinton made it up she
even told a president the Durham report
she told Biden and she told Obama she
was going to do it to get rid of her
email Scandal so what did they do the
FBI lied they went to a fisa court judge
they lied three more times they needed
to get this guy and then they see they
violated the Fourth Amendment rights of
one American in spite on a presidential
candidate and we now know it was all a
hoax started by Hillary Clinton but that
wasn't enough then what we had is the
FBI telling social media you can expect
that there's going to be Russian
disinformation in the form of 100 byton
laptop and that's when they interfered
with the presidential election for the
second time and 51 CIA intelligence
agents so we've got the doj the FBI the
CIA say oh this is Russian
disinformation when we know damn well it
wasn't Russian disinformation and now
what you've got is a loser prosecutor
Jack Smith who's been slapped down by
the United States Supreme Court in his
in one of his prosecutions that if I
were a lawyer I would give up my law
license I'd be so embarrassed hiding
under a rock he's the one who prosecuted
John Edwards He's got a political agenda
and this is all over presidential
records act which is a civil civil suit
a civil issue and so what they do is
they put out this narrative indictment
oh this is a story of wrongdoing
National Defense and let's put in
Espionage we can kind of tie it into the
Russian collusion so people people say
oh it could have been the Russians this
is nonsense and I want to know how many
documents were altered how many
documents were destroyed zero zero but
who destroyed 33 000 documents that she
lied about over and over again Hillary
Clinton she destroyed them that was
tampering with evidence that was
obstruction of justice and did the doj
the FBI care they didn't give a damn but
now they care what are they so afraid of
let him run for office and if he loses
then that's the end of it I hate a
country that is akin to a third world
country this is a Banana Republic when
you indict one guy running for president
and the guy who's doing it in some old
geezer who says you know what I don't
know anything about it the day by the
way the day that we finally get under
threat of contempt to the head of the
FBI we finally get a 10 23 from a
credible FBI Source credible two hundred
thousand dollars worth of credibility
the f FBI paid him saying Joe took 5
million Hunter took 5 million from
Ukraine and I'm not done yet I'll tell
you something else this whole thing with
Ukraine why the heck is everybody going
to Ukraine why do we put billions and
billions and billions of dollars into
Ukraine what the heck is going on over
there Randy Weingarten going to check
out education and Joe Biden goes over
there in January of 2018 and he says if
you don't get the prosecutor off that
company where my son makes eighty
thousand dollars a month and if you
don't get rid of him I'm not going to
give you the billion dollars that the
United States promised you well Joe
that's called
pay to play it's an organized criminal
Enterprise that we have as a president
and his family they should be ashamed
and every American should be ashamed of
what happened today
well said
Jessica I assume you agree with most of
that
[Laughter]
I was struck by
mostly the fact that she didn't address
the documents that were panning across
the screen that there were documents
found in the bathroom in the shower in
the Ballroom in his bedroom in his
office
that there were documents pertaining to
our nuclear programs pertaining to our
weaknesses and our allies weaknesses
what makes us vulnerable clearly a
national security risk what has been
proven time and time again when it comes
to this particular case is that Donald
Trump and all the supporters have been
lying to us about what happened so first
he went with everyone everything was
Declassified because he's magic and he
could look at things and they become
Declassified now he's on tape admitting
the fact that he's showing people Mark
Meadows this team when he's trying to do
the book a document that was still
classified and that he knows that he
doesn't have the power to Declassified
it anymore because he's no longer
president he said they were properly
secured I don't think a toilet is a
skiff Maybe I'm Wrong better than a
Corvette yeah here you go misdirection
misdirection yes it is because no it's
not because in the B Block we'll talk
about Ukraine and then I can hear about
Victor shoken all over again
he also said that he complied with
everything we know he flouted subpoenas
and now we know that he asked his
lawyers to get rid of things
it seems and yes I I'm not a lawyer
but I'm decently smart I know some
viewers don't necessarily think that but
I'm telling you and a few of my teachers
would agree that this seems like a
pretty clear case of obstruction and
Jonathan turley's been on our air all
day talking about this and saying that
these charges are The Darlings
of what they're looking for because they
are easy to prove especially when you
have pictures of them so if Hillary
actually does get rid of them here we go
this has nothing to do with Hillary
Clinton no it doesn't if you want to
argue and you want to talk about again
the difference between gross negligence
and extremely careless a lot of people
have that conversation but today you are
looking at boxes of classified documents
strewn across a public place also that
were transported to another location
even to the point who whoever the family
member who texts I won't be able to fit
all the boxes on the plane whatever
shall we do come on get it but as the
judge did say these are presidential
personal records which he has the sole
authority to make personal just as the
Bill Clinton sock drawer case proved and
just as an Obama judge ratified that is
the law it's a civil situation it's not
criminal so this is all nothing well and
I'll tell you why it does matter and
it's not just deflection to talk about
Hillary Clinton and to talk about Joe
Biden and Hunter Biden the fact that
classified documents that were taken by
Joe Biden when he was a Senator ended up
in his garage where Hunter Biden who has
a lengthy Shady record of engaging with
people like I don't know hookers who are
all over his his laptop Shady foreign
figures Chinese spies there's no
question about you know whether he was
possibly allowing them into the house
when Joe Biden wasn't around just
sitting in the garage not to mention he
was making these foreign deals with
Shady figures who did not have the
interests of the United States in mind
they have an interest of how they can
bribe and make sure that their interest
whether it's for the Chinese Communist
party or for Ukraine to be a changed in
their favor the fact is that Hillary
Clinton had a digital
box of an unclassified or an unsecure
server with classified information on it
as a secretary of state after she left
that office in her bathroom so if you
want to talk about how this is all bad
sure you should not mishandle classified
information but the double standard of
Justice in this country is becoming a
serious problem not for Donald Trump
alone but for everyday Americans who are
looking at their federal government and
going it's being weaponized against
people who disagree with the left and
we've seen that over and over and over
again and the Department of Justice puts
out this indictment it looks bad they
always do at the beginning and then the
narrative completely falls apart once
there's a response days weeks months
later from Trump and from the actual
evidence that we see we'll see what
happens on Tuesday we'll see what
happens with the trial but when it comes
to The credibility of doj because
they've gone through this list of
witch hunts as the President says for
years eight years of this over and over
again with different situations they
have no credibility left so even if
these things are true in the indictment
nobody's going to believe it and that's
a problem for American democracy as a
left it was a grand jury verdict though
this is the same thing you're acting and
the jury wasn't full of Andy McCabe
Peter strzok and George Soros they were
a jury of his peers it's just an
indictment it doesn't mean anything it
hasn't even gone to trial the grand jury
is a jury of his peers the people who
were selected yeah well you have a juror
of your peers when they get to your both
sides
Mr Gutfeld yes thank you I love my name
I don't this isn't I think most people
understand this isn't about breaking
laws it's about breaking Trump uh even
the charges are theatric I mean dozens
of many indictments you know basically
like they just chopped up a candy bar
into little bite-sized snacks it's meant
to exhaust and overwhelm not just Trump
but his supporters right it's meant to
psychologically flood the Zone up to the
election to keep Trump's persuasive
abilities at Bay to keep Trump's
supporters occupied to scare away donors
right yep nobody's going to want to give
money if they think that he's going to
go to jail uh we know that this whole
classified document stuff is a murky
place it's like everybody knows that so
this is like the choice to do this is
definitely and only definitely a
political one the problem though is with
this exhaustion strategy you think it
wears people down but when you look at
Trump supporters and trump it winds them
up oh yeah I don't think the Democrats
or the media ever ever understood that
concept or the bigger concept which is
always their uh problem the concept of
going too far
you know they don't they don't
understand limits right so you have no
limits in Criminal Justice Reform where
is that going you have no limits on the
woke gender nonsense right so when you
come out against at the surgical
mutilation of children they accuse you
of being transphobic because they don't
understand the limit they don't
understand if you say you want to border
your your xenophobic because they don't
understand the limit the persecution of
trump and not the prosecution is based
on the fact that they have no limit they
don't understand they because they
classified him as worse than Hitler you
can do anything so you have leaks piled
up charges and overwhelming antipathy
toward Trump that is creating this
Relentless Witch Hunt and you think that
trotting out this stuff is going to
alienate him no it just feeds their
energy when you were taking when you're
taking their candidate off the stage do
you think they're just gonna walk away
from that you're taking their choice of
President 75 million people know what
you're doing it's not about Trump it's
about his voters when you investigate
Joe Biden nobody cares about
his voters nobody does we know why they
voted for Joe they they didn't like
Trump but you go after Trump something
different happens you go after the
people that support him you were and
when you arrest your rival you think
that people think the election in 2020
was corrupt you think they're going to
buy the results of this they are
worsening a divide right they're pouring
salt on a wound because they don't care
about the people they only care about
the politics and that's all I gotta say
well said everybody hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else